promised a tough life there's nothing
your work enjoy it I married a minion
let me look at me man is this cool guys
I know you are but what am i yeah i'm
hatsune yeah that was silly work that
you guys were here you gotta go check
out a really good my name belief nation
today is day we're going to home I'm
excited I don't know anyone else gonna
stress out I am yes I'm very stressed
out no matter acts of death row good
morning
we're excited first time any of us if
it's Universal Studios so it's a new
adventure for all of us we're doing it
because kids wanna see Harry Potter
stuff so I'm
[Applause]
and they don't like anal Kingdom so
maybe next year we'll take one day last
vacation but for this year we're going
to go to it I don't think I don't even
we're going to go to Universal and we're
heading there now
here we go we're making our way first
stop is going to be the crazy worm face
it's not true first stop is Starbucks
for Nina look at the happy smile pretty
big penis having happy golf ball it's
mini golf you want to go mini golfing
we'll spend the whole day mini golfing
instead of universal just everyone to
know okay Starbucks first company now
who's meaningful Kate it kind of this is
much excitement you get believe in the
morning shorter lines shorter lines and
Disney I like
[Music]
and instantly better
all right guys first up Harry Potter
free Forbidden Journey women Harry
Potter ride Wow this PC excitement is
real
[Music]
this cool guys whoa
there's the castle we're gonna go in
there you ready yeah I think so yeah
you're free to go oh yeah you're ready
we're going inside the castle there it
is
[Music]
like to bring anything in I got to put
everything in the lockers with the
camera so see you guys on the other side
what do we think with their thumbs up
how are they okay
Lina was scared yeah you know he's
scared totally work that you guys were
here
you gotta go check out a really next up
flight of the Hippogriff we're going on
with you ready let's do it
[Music]
these guys are cheap here don't let you
film anything don't like to film
anything but how was it it it had fun it
was fast this is pretty cool I was
tempted to pull out the camera anyway
you know me they can see the capacitor
okay next up we're going to go to King
Kong pretty cool maybe a little scary
for the kid are you doing yeah hey -
it's Gary who's good he's next to her
pretty amazing man oh goody amazing
ahead David was not happy they killed
these giant bugs and it sprayed water
all over us pretty fun
okay man spider-man let's go something
tells me they're not gonna be filming
spider-man
so I'll take some b-roll on my way there
you guys least get a sense of party
[Music]
it's pretty cool pretty cool inside a
little really good job - Oh what did you
think guys scary no it's nothing like
fun
[Music]
[Applause]
all right next up we're going on some
water ride
water I know what's always foggy cloud
that I find sometimes I think so now I
don't know you're excited name is
excited to go on water right hey Pete
the cool off yeah I know you are but
what am I here I'm hot - yeah
we're gonna go on there yeah yeah let's
go here so now you're excited all right
all right time to put the camera away
don't wanna get wet here we go
we all got snow look at me a hot mess up
my hair
Lena Lena is taking water out of her
pants how you doin inna freezing
everything is soaked here they come
this sucks party Lena's hair is amazing
whoo we're not going to go on the
waterfall one kids can't handle it all
away you call this a publicist off life
doesn't happen your work enjoy it such a
complainer
this is nothing you think what to try be
an entrepreneur guys just try opening
your own business you think this is the
rough life you know you don't know pain
no pain start your own company this is
nothing oh all right no waterfall rides
these kids need to toughen up pump it up
right what do you guys think how you
doing
it's wet but we don't complain in this
family right okay I'll have to figure
out where we're going next is not going
to be the waterfall right this is the
ride we are not going on
[Music]
and guys just water alright let's keep
going another are the kids don't want to
go on they might get a little bit wet
look nobody's soaking their hair where
you think we're gonna do it Bobby
we're going to go hey t want to go Lena
Jeffrey if you want to go Nina
all right the boys want to do it just in
the middle okay there's the thing and
tie up with the camera we're here
I was a guy like the exam it's time to
go eat at the Harry Potter right drive
and get our 1 let's go all right lunch
time we got fish and chips and
shepherd's pie fish and chips and yeah
that's why your fish and chips in the
Harry Potter themed restaurant with a
special look look at the clock see what
it says we're getting married
pretty cool eh
Oh
how was it Jimmy
alright - what's the time - what's the
time - what's the time - what are you
doing
why buy some magic wand let's go so
every year we have this policy that the
kids get to pick one thing as the
president to have to like it in our
house every toy in the store and they
all decided to debate it one by one and
see all the vendors one shot so we sit
for the last day and we're about to go I
might ask you just like 50 bucks so on
budget let's do it to the kid who's that
[Music]
I think so you want you got a Death
Eaters one assist you on it are you
happy
all right let's see you cast a spell
how's the wife doing okay tired what
some caffeine no want some water polo
water we're going to be leaving that
this side of universal studios pop it on
Hogwarts Express and going to London the
other side alright once again the last
film good job Universal Studios what you
mean into London everything I have more
fun
[Music]
through the wall ready diagonally pretty
unreal
again very without filming thankful
where I'm going to share with you guys
but we'll have some fun in this well
another really fun ride and also does a
good job
Venus screen the whole time and almost a
lot of a chair you're behind me like
here on the side anymore
Pacifica the fun yeah yeah all right
good let's keep it moving more rides to
come
[Music]
next up men in black it's a ride some
men in black ride do it hey guess what
no chambers again yeah Universal Studios
so to go on the right when you gotta put
this stuff in the lockers there which
everything and in the classic lineup
forget the stuff I which
pain in the front I think if we come
back leader
Phil frame by or don't come by Universal
you got a deal with each other next
right up is the simpson dr
[Music]
Simpsons right
[Music]
I'm nauseous are you doing okay
[Music]
all right kids
next up the minions ride let's do some
mean I married a minion
I mean she likes banana I feel like man
Nina what did you have for breakfast
today
please
I married a minion all right so another
motion simulator lots of maybe noxious
long assistant went out with the kids
sitting about
taking time for
I was it was it good you enjoyed what I
have enjoyed probably not no it's not
that it's not that bad alright last
thing of the day then we go home on
overnights all shut-in for he bloody
the indictment is Andriy still shocked
14 here we go how was it long good crop
ice cream ice cream ice cream
alright kids are having ice cream Nina
got a huge one how's the ice cream kids
you got cotton candy yummy
sucking on milk and cookies I think Nina
got the ginormous Chocolate Chunk Oh
typical caramel chance something and
there's mine yeah
yeah
alright that's it for us today thank you
guys for joining us hope you enjoy some
fun yeah baby ride of the day Wow wasn't
Harry Potter the water me know my ice
cream wow you know that comes to get my
students to help with Ben and Jerry's
everywhere thank you guys for watching
continue to believe I can do whatever
she wants okay I'm Nina this is Nina car
my dog that's how we roll